Well.
Well well go to your mom's house
Christina,
cause it's interesting.
God bless him Nigga.
I'm blessed right now.
Yeah,
I'm talking about
God bless is a nick.
God blesses
God is God is real.
God blesses a Nigga.
If you got stabbed 12 times,
why the fuck are you still standing on that street that you just got stabbed on?
What don't you never go there?
No fucking go there anymore.
And if you get shot on a certain neighborhood,
don't go to the neighborhood.
What's your with job,
Nicole?
Hi,
nick is blessed.
Dammit.
Ali sent that in.
It's called Pastor [inaudible] sermon 74
thanks asshole.
You were assholes.
That was so old.
Yeah.
And what episode was that too?
I don't know how long ago.
It was awhile ago and it was definitely a while ago.
Look at you and blue van.
So thrilled with yourselves or your,
looks like you're hydrating with some coffee.
No,
it looks like I'm hydrating with a full,
oh,
I drank,
drank half of it before the show.
Where's your water bottle?
Oh,
I have ones.
Where is it Macy
even hiding that.
It's interesting.
I see you caffeine in front of you.
Yeah.
Why Hydro Down?
Dehydrate the same time.
Cause I know what I'm doing.
This is so childish.
It's you.
You're so childish.
You drank like Ellis drinks out of a sippy cup.
Oh.
Oh,
that's it.
That's all.
You got one sip.
I know that you think you do volume.
Look next to me.
I have this one,
a backup
and a third.
That's antiques.
I drank it all Frankie last week.
No,
it's always here.
Hello.
Can we get a new this?
Please
let us take on a microphone and you guys are terrible both and keep you both
sound like Tom.
Like get that bitch
real.
Okay.
Check it out.
Thank you.
Wet Not sac.
Um,
it was great.
I had a blast with you guys.
Absolutely blind.
Did you blast a lot there?
But I didn't.
No,
no.
That's surprising.
But it was a really fun shows and I think,
oh you Jews for coming out.
I'm sorry.
There's a huge Hasidic Jewish population.
No,
I,
they all stayed in my hotel last time.
I was there like acidic.
Um,
is that what you are moving or Ashkenazi connection?
What?
Are you serious?
He's just a type I know.
Has said Eric.
I said Eric Ashkenazi and Sammy Davis.
What kind is there?
You can't hear what he's saying.
Oh yeah,
it works when you put your mid on there.
There we go.
Yeah.
Well Ashkenazi is like a white Jew.
Safari is a Spanish.
June.
The city is just religious.
So listen,
there you go.
It's too complicated.
Yeah.
You guys are so commonly.
I think the real problem is that there's too many of you.
So let's make America great again.
Anyways,
next week I'm in a dribbly brown shit.
He the liberty township.
That's,
that's really good.
That's by a Christie submitted that dribble the dribbly brown shit.
It's uh,
just outside of the Greater Cincinnati area.
That means I'm coming home.
James.
Oh my God.
I haven't been to my hometown in a while.
Are you going to take a pilgrimage to the hotel that it,
how do you think?
Of course,
and blue bands coming with me.
Are you going to stay in room six one eight,
you'll see,
oh shit.
The raking the truth of our lives.
Well,
should I,
should I clear my calendar and join you guys?
What would the baby and
make it a family event?
Well,
I mean,
it's kind of a big deal.
We just sit there and weep for a week
after that.
I am going to,
uh,
where am I going?
Uh,
oh man.
Manly bloat.
Hi,
someone's,
someone sent this one in a Goddamn San Diego.
What is it?
Manly.
Daigo no,
God.
Uncle Chichi I think is it is from the man man to lay blow.
I don't know.
Somebody put it command,
I dunno.
Anyways,
it's San Diego.
Um,
man,
Diego,
we always call him and Diego.
Yeah,
but somebody put like blow it Daigo or something like that.
That goes good.
So I'm in blower Daigo at the American comedy company and I'm very much looking
forward to that.
Those tickets are really going
fast.
Always do well in that area.
Such bullshit,
by the way.
Oh,
you'll see.
You think,
I don't know that this guy didn't pick it up for you on the way in today.
Do you think that this is the only thing that you're going to get loaded on
this episode?
You don't think that you're going to get this?
This is the beginning.
Maybe I was just going to sit back.
Do you know that you're dealing with,
come on,
you're just upset because I won last episode with the water champions.
You're,
you don't even know what's going to happen,
so I'm scared.
But you should be okay.
You should be terrified anyways.
Um,
you,
I know you're,
you're ramping up for some big,
cause you did the n I double g song.
If we get back to the dates,
July 14 through 16 is as a Daigo and then,
uh,
Saint [inaudible],
Missouri.
July 10,
July 21st through 23rd.
Um,
and then I have a bunch of dates added.
I'm going to Charlotte,
North Carolina.
Classic Standard.
Yeah.
Going to come up.
Come all over.
Blow us,
come blow us Ohio.
I love.
Come blow us fun.
Fartlek Adelphia Jude Dork kitties.
That's my favorite.
Yeah.
So there are titties Israeli.
Good.
Please go to Thomson grow.com.
There's shows page hit the show's page.
All the tickets are their jeans.
I know you've got some days.
I do.
I'm doing one night or
I'm back.
I'm back in the rotation starting September 27th,
Seattle,
Washington at the Tacoma.
On your comedy clubs.
So technically,
oh,
stop it.
You're showing off now to come on your comedy club.
September 28th,
Portland or again at helium,
comedy,
stubborn helium,
comedy club.
October 4th.
What's Dallas?
Dallas.
Dallas,
Texas.
Hyenas,
comedy club.
October 5th and a fuck my Holston.
Yeah.
Houston.
Uh,
at the secret group.
October 23rd,
I have added a date.
Indianapolis,
Indiana,
mortise comedy club.
So get your tickets@thousandranch.com.
That's thousands with the word spelled out.
ranch.com.
Come see me guys.
See me drink water on stage because that's what I do.
I hydrate 24,
seven.
Okay.
Yeah.
Are you done?
Y'All don't y'all finish.
I finished and I'm done.
Um,
so much exciting,
airy,
uh,
things to talk about this episode.
But first we got to take care of our business jeans.
Oh yeah.
May I say to everybody,
if you use Amazon,
I do hope you're using our banner.
Go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom of the homepage and deer shopping as you
normally would.
It just helps to show even having an,
we have an Amazon Canada banner as well.
We do.ca,
ca,
ca.
Yo,
all right.
Here we go.
Jeans.
Oh Shit.
No.
This has not,
nothing to do with you,
I promise.
Yeah,
right.
I promise.
If you do not drive to the rest of you,
do not push herself.
Don't be the greatest.
Yeah,
we'll accomplish nothing.
Yeah.
How badly
do you
water?
Okay.
Don't bring in one loving to them.
Well,
no.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay,
you're going to throw up.
so you shouldn't drink a gallon of fluid and an hour.
I want to stare at an old boss to drink a gallon of milk and an hour.
It's different,
but I think it's a gallon of any fluid shouldn't do that and so I was going to
knock it out.
I'm just drinking like I don't want to drink.
Oh Bull Shit.
Bull Shit.
I've known you for so long.
So look at this.
Look at the Burke shaved.
He looks worse than I thought.
You got it.
You got to grow it back,
dude.
Got To get that mouth,
Huh?
Little checklists and then he's got a one big one though.
No,
that,
yeah,
that I tried and stick in the front.
Yeah.
That thing.
That's how you start your apples right there.
You got that.
You going to get anything going?
I think he has two or three on the bottom and that's it.
It is amazing that this guy decides that he is going to motivate people to
strive to be that best.
He's not even motivated to get his teeth fixed.
He's not motivated for shit.
He's only motivation was to turn a camera on.
But that's the thing,
right?
He's clearly got a lot of things to work and you got really fired up in this
thing.
You know he's real fat and sweaty.
If you do not thrive,
thrive,
or strive to add some more teeth,
we know the answer cause you're supposed to strive to be the best when you're
missing teeth versus,
and you strive to be the best.
Thrive.
If you do not drive
fry her,
don't be the greatest tape.
We'll accomplish nothing.
That's true actually.
Gladly.
Do you
cause
this guy?
Where'd you find him?
On Instagram.
And I don't even put it motivated the shit out of me that day I was sitting
around in the hotel and wet and that sac and I go,
I'm gonna hit the gym.
Yeah.
And the dentist.
Did you make that boy,
I bought some floss right away.
Jesus.
I'm not as bad.
Look,
there's a lot to go over,
but we should point out the fact that we got new shirts on dude.
Oh
we did it.
This has been a dream and we finally achieved that.
It had happened were wearing double pipe of classic shirts.
Look at that design.
Very rare.
Very rare is the tag.
And um,
this is no shit.
You know,
a top dog obviously contributed to,
uh,
this,
this design coming along and sharing his,
his expertise on them.
Yeah.
And then last week after we recorded the show,
right,
we had lunch downstairs,
sat down.
And if you go to Christina's Instagram,
yeah,
you can see me.
I got a thumb up and a thumbs down.
It happened.
I had a double pipe classic in front of her.
And Ah,
I mean,
I watched you cry for anything.
So station.
Yeah.
It was [inaudible] son was there to witness,
you know,
that I looked at the photo and I realized I'm in shock in the photo.
Right.
I go like,
oh,
like if you can see my face,
I'm like,
why?
Right.
It just happened.
What's just right.
And I noted the time,
even on the Instagram post.
Yeah.
Uh,
that it happened.
It was incredible.
Really incredible.
Well,
and what's funny is that it,
you know,
like with all double pipe classics,
it's a surprise.
You know,
you think you're just going to burp or you're just going to fart and then it
happens and it,
you know,
and it's like you don't really,
right.
Yeah,
that's right after it happened.
Look at your posts.
Right?
3:17 PM.
June 20th,
2016.
I witness Tom having a double five classic.
They're extremely rare and you can't force them.
You can't make it rain.
Look at the shock.
Yeah.
The Dutch is,
look how thin you are there.
Look how skinny you look.
I know some people that don't look,
that is um,
that's the moment man.
That was right right after it happened.
Yeah.
So we now have a double pipe,
classic shirts.
They're uh,
uh,
your mom's house,
podcast.com there also,
uh,
in,
in my store,
Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com if you go to the shop page,
it's also there and it's just really exciting.
Now,
do you remember,
I remember you were kind of leaning over because you were,
I just think how did it have such a magical moment?
We had,
I think it was towards the end of lunch ordered Sushi and um,
just finished wrapping it up.
And I,
I remember feeling which was what did I feel coming first.
I think I felt the fart brewing and cause that's when you leaned over and it
looks impressive as I leaned over,
came out of the top of the same time.
And it was,
it wasn't,
you know,
that's the thing.
It's not burp fart.
It's not fart.
Burp both.
Boom.
That's why it's so rare.
That's why we wrote very rare because gas usually chooses a path that goes,
I'm going up or I'm going down.
Right.
And the thing that happens with every double pipe classic is that you don't
immediately know it happened because you're in shock.
So when you did it,
hence like you did it and we both went,
oh,
that was a double pipe.
Yeah.
They're just,
they are so rare.
And it was so neat that it happened right after we had just discussed it.
And Yeah,
I dunno.
It's an amazing thing for me too,
is that it's really even more rare if I could say so to have a witness for one,
sometimes you're alone and it's like,
oh,
you did.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
But when you have a witness,
there's no one can take it away from you.
That's true.
You know,
it's like your college education and your double pipes.
Yeah.
People are there for it.
So it was really,
really something and we're very excited.
We're very excited and wanted a double pipe,
classic shirt.
And then this,
this is the one man,
this is very rarely nice material off to it fits like a glove.
I love it.
Shipping is included for all domestic offers.
That's true.
I have,
what's great about this shirt too is that it's on the down low.
You know,
only other monies are really going to get it right.
And it doesn't say like Fart on it.
It's kind of subtle.
Some people,
when I picked it up from the shirt
place,
the guy was asking me,
he's like,
is this like a like an x games event or something really,
really bad.
Did you Clinton?
Yeah.
What did he say?
It was like,
oh,
better the next games.
Yeah,
you should send this to Tony Hawk.
Alright.
Pipe.
Right.
So they're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Similar,
but not really.
I bet he's probably like,
Ooh,
I wish I could have one of those.
Wish I could have a double pipe classic.
Maybe you will sir,
if you live long enough,
if you pray hard enough,
he just has to live long enough.
I think that is the secret.
And don't force it.
Just be open to what happened.
I want to say I had one in 2015 and I want to say,
I don't remember when it happened.
I don't think you did.
Well maybe 2014 2014 yeah.
So that's how long?
Two years man.
Yeah,
he up anyways.
Okay.
You know,
it's just because I just,
I think you're really lucky in that you married someone who thinks that burps
and farts are super funny.
But I really like when you burp and make a sound like you just did,
like,
like when you go,
Yup.
Or like,
just,
especially when you're doing in front of your mom in Florida or when she's
around,
she's like,
ah,
and she's coming,
you know?
I know.
Yeah.
I love it.
Cause she gets mad at you for Bourbon and then she gets mad at me for laughing
at your birth.
So it's like we get a double upset.
Charl yeah.
I'm going to try to get her in here just to talk to her for awhile.
Yup.
I'll do some verbs in front of her just to get her to go.
Because when,
no matter how much I hate,
no matter how much I hate you or we're fighting,
if you go,
Yup.
It makes me laugh every time.
No matter how much I hate.
Look how you might get for fighting or something.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Um,
so who was this guy?
This guy you're going to fall.
So in love with it,
I promise you are so toothy old old TUPE tubes.
Oh,
got me thinking about motivation.
And then I also saw this guy,
oddly enough also on instant saw part of this.
Yeah.
And so I had a blue band pull it,
just,
um,
just give him a lift.
And His name is Daniel Pena and he's a businessman who also is a,
uh,
a coach,
like a mentor to people in the business world.
Okay.
And this is that one of his seminars.
He just dumbed down and shut off that part of his grain and just follow the
steps.
You don't need fucking case studies.
Okay?
You have a,
you have a fucking template.
You have a mother fucking script that a fucking monkey
that Alex wants a fucking case study because he wants to know the shit behind it
cause he's stupid.
And that's why he's cooking poor.
You don't need any motherfucking
case study.
How many fucking times do I have to say you had the fucking script?
I said,
don't change a fucking word on the script.
Not a comma.
I love it if it's got misrep fucking one sending out Ms. Bell.
The last thing you fucker need is a fucking case study.
They're all,
this is why you're fucking pad or this is why the cock sucker watching this on
youtube.
I saw a fucking hole
again.
Again.
Oh,
there's so much in the $50 million man.
Why?
Yeah.
God,
I love your writing glove is a guy.
That's why you're fucking poor.
Oh,
it's so good.
Is Pretty well known.
Paying.
Yeah.
Pena for not [inaudible] very often.
That's my kind of Bro.
Oh,
I love this guy.
Hanging out with losers.
Wasting your time.
What?
Harassing you.
Okay.
Show me your friends and I'll show you your future.
That's one of your top.
Top it is three pieces.
Show me your friends and I show you your future.
You want to know why you're all fucked up?
Let's look at the fucking bummed you're hang around with.
Or is this everybody in my family in eastern bloc?
Shit.
Are you sure?
His last name isn't like budgets without,
can you picture him like you're at the table and him telling you yes.
This is a shit I heard grow by the way.
Yes.
This is
one of,
by the way,
and I'm not a,
uh,
a coach obviously for people.
This is one of life's great truths.
Yeah.
If you are in a place right now where you're like,
man,
like Shit's just not working out.
Yeah.
I wish I had more going.
I'm really bummed out about this.
Yeah.
Look who you're hanging out with.
It's true.
These are always the truth.
You know,
losers,
man.
You want to know why you're all fucked up.
Look at the fucking bomb.
Did I get
future?
You want to know why you're all fucked up?
Because look at the fucking bummed you're hanging around.
I wish I could play that for so many people.
I know.
I really do.
Everybody needs to hear this guy.
This guy's the right family members that need to see that.
Somebody needs to see that.
Yeah,
he's right.
He's totally,
this is the guru.
This is who people should be listening to.
Yeah.
Not fucking Oprah and Dr Phil.
This is the guy.
He's right.
You're hanging out with fucking losers.
Yeah.
Play more and more.
Okay,
good.
I got to get him on that,
right?
Why you're fucking pad or,
okay,
sorry.
That was just the best.
That's just an ISO.
Did you,
did you ISO,
Iso,
this one thing?
What's his name again?
Daniel Pena,
man.
I gotta look this.
Brian,
do you have that whole thing in here?
The whole thing or no?
Holy Shit on the cheat sheets there.
Okay.
I must know more.
So is he like a billionaire or something?
Well,
the,
I dunno businessman.
Yeah.
I love him so much is the one I want to play for you and your friends are
fucking losers.
You're a loser.
He's right.
You're hanging out losers.
You're going to be a fucking loser and hang out with winners,
man.
Holy Shit.
I used to hear this growing up all the time.
This is the way my parents used to talk to me.
I mean it.
I mean my dad has said the same thing.
Sometimes we exchange emails and I'm like,
why does Dan have to be such a cunt?
Why does he have to push it?
Why does he have to always want to know I'm being just the opposite of a
country.
That's right.
You're a cunt,
Brian,
not me.
Explain,
yeah,
you're weak
and you're showing you and you want these people to like you and you're telling
me I'm weak on that email
because you love me because you care.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Thank you very much,
guys related to be crazy and you can be more than you are at these little cons.
Think that you're something now I see you a thousand times more.
Yeah.
See,
they have low standards.
These fucking weenies to watch his fucking thing.
I know.
I know what you can be.
They think you're a big fucking deal.
I know you're not
down deep inside brine.
No.
That I'm closer to being right than they are.
You don't agree with me 100% fine,
but you know I'm close to and white than they are.
You're not the all end off shit.
Who gives a fuck and the cosmos the time.
You are not a fart in the wind you need.
No one is exactly what you won't.
You always worry to be a thousand times better.
Just like it.
My daughter who's a British citizen,
this is HD butter.
That British,
a line of furniture.
Oh really?
That's the showroom.
It's in.
You know what I'm saying?
It's a furniture store to do this.
This is that British furniture company.
Probably.
It's,
it's all the same company furniture.
Anyway,
that was really exciting.
Yeah.
I really liked this guy.
Does he have a book I can read?
I don't know if he has a book.
I have more audio of him.
Absolutely.
He's really spectacular.
They think you're a big fucking deal.
I know you're not,
you're a cunt.
And to talk to me about what,
what's,
I mean for those first few days,
what would have been the reactions from people?
Do you get people that want to leave?
Do you get people that want to cry?
Just talking about,
so this guy,
he lives in a castle in Scotland.
Oh cool.
In your opinion.
Does good for the winter.
That's why.
And people pay a lot of money to go and sit in like that room that you,
you heard him telling people you're fucking poor that's at his castle.
I love it.
So these are people who,
you know,
his story is that he turned,
uh,
I think it was $8 into 430 million so that he had,
he was some high ranking executive and an oil company.
And I dunno,
he's been a,
he's been a coach for business people,
but he just has this persona,
you know,
sort of some people cause you can tell not to push him.
I mean you must,
you must have to know you a little bit or not push him.
No,
no.
We've had people piss their pants.
We've had people pass out.
Yeah,
we've had people,
shit,
their pants,
a partner in a big four accounting forum.
Shit,
his pants.
The person that passed that was a psychiatrist.
We've got Harvard medical doctors.
We've got pass out.
Why would they,
I mean they just did.
Okay.
Just the stress,
the stress of hanging out with this.
We can you imagine that?
The stress being around me make people pass out Pearson shit themselves.
What a psycho.
I love it.
Has anyone ever said fuck you damn pain?
Yeah,
I'm walking out the door.
No,
I've thrown a couple out,
but nobody's ever said that.
No,
I take that back.
One one Romanian walked out the door because he said I was making fun of them
calling them a Gypsy Roma.
But then when we came back in the afternoon,
he was sitting in the library and I thought,
I thought you left.
He says,
no,
no.
You were right.
I'll be the first.
If I walk,
if you walk you'll be,
well,
you'd be,
there'd be plenty of guns here,
but you may be the first cut the walk out.
You gotta get to Scotland.
Geez.
I want to sign up for the similar stuff and it'd be like,
can we simulcasts this on your mom's house?
I got to go.
Can you please,
can you please send how much it is?
Let's find out.
Let's go.
It's true.
Shit.
Me,
Megan,
do it.
Can you put a gun to buy every fucking person that you email?
Skype.
Fuck,
fuck.
Linked,
fucked and wha what?
What are you goals on this other side of the paper?
They have anything to do with hilarious length.
Lincoln didn't fuck cause it's for fucking losers.
This he
p heads watching this thing like me.
You said they're either going to love you or hate you.
I knew which one it would be.
All my life.
I've been this way and all my life.
People love me and respect me.
Wow.
If you're in a foxhole put,
do you want him to fucking Fox with you?
Be Fine.
You want some mealy mouth con asshole or you want somebody to do that in a rip
their head off and shit down their neck.
I'm in love.
I told you,
I think I'm in love,
Tom.
Sorry.
I love this guy.
I listen to everything he says.
Yeah.
God Damn.
I wish she taught a school seriously.
I'd send my kid to his school to teach them not to be fucking pussies.
Right.
Like today.
The kids that,
you know,
these kids are fucking mollycoddled.
That's how old school.
I love it.
I love old school craziness like this.
It's great.
Uh,
it makes me so happy.
It doesn't that make you feel safer in the world when there are people like him.
Well,
you need,
you need guys like that.
No,
you do.
You need like no nonsense.
Normal people.
Yeah.
God,
I made me feel like I was a home again.
I liked it.
There was,
I know it.
It feels real familiar,
right?
No,
it's my parents.
The,
everyone talks like this where I,
where I came from,
honestly,
like to have a,
like Americans who are nice and stuff,
that freaks me out.
That makes me feel uncomfortable when a guys like this guy,
this,
this could be my mom.
Yeah.
Mom and dad.
So it just feels so familiar.
It feels right at home,
man.
Ah,
I felt good.
There's one here.
I don't,
I don't see it in here,
but he,
he did,
he did an interview in a car.
Do you remember that one?
Oh,
that's my baby.
Next one.
I know.
He did an interview in a car where this guy's like,
how's it going?
He goes,
great sun shines out of my asshole.
And like,
I was like,
all right.
You can tell him no one's prepared for it.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
He's got quite a map.
It,
it,
it does sound like your,
your family.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's really my dad taught.
My mother would talk like this more.
Yeah.
This guy's probably mentally ill too.
I'm serious.
It might be right.
Hey,
uh,
do you want to Persian lady a voicemail update?
I would love one.
I fucking love.
One time.
She's a fucking loser.
Fucked up.
Fucking bumps.
Quitting.
No losers.
Um,
so here's the,
uh,
here's the voicemail from last week.
Hello.
Interlock.
[inaudible] groceries from immune bag on my time.
Your [inaudible].
Oh my God.
The [inaudible].
Oh,
I going to tell Angela Martin called [inaudible].
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I don't play [inaudible].
Okay.
Yes,
I still fishing
Jesus.
Oh my God.
We're always waiting for the,
uh,
for the,
you know,
the,
the scoop on what's really going on here.
Oh my God.
We know that this is,
this goes deep,
you know,
I mean,
this course,
these messages never stopped coming in.
I want to credit,
do you know who left us?
Who set this in?
Um,
no.
No.
God.
Hmm.
Okay.
Well,
uh,
we got an actual person,
um,
and I'm sorry,
we're not crediting you correctly.
Who sent in an MP three.
So he actually says what she said.
That's so much better.
Yeah,
it's great.
So this is what she is saying.
Okay.
Hello?
Salamay those plastic bags I told you about.
Put those ones that you get tomatoes and herbs from the supermarket.
Put them on your trees.
Oh my God.
Those chipmunks and not going up there at all.
They keep eating my figs and keep worrying that they're going to eat all my
blackberry's now.
They're not touching them at all.
I feel so good.
They've all disappeared now hurry up and grab those bags.
I've got to do the same.
Put them all over on your branches.
Start from the bottom and work your way up to the top.
Those motor sluts have all disappeared now.
Okay,
talk to you soon.
That's amazing.
Please.
So great.
Of course,
by the way,
it might be really mentally.
Start from the bottom put.
She's putting this lady grocery bags all over trees.
You understand him?
Horrible.
Must not look in her house.
You got to give some to to the animals.
So that's the way it works.
It's like animals get away with that shit.
Squirrels.
They're probably suffocating.
No,
I'm just like,
oh,
thanks a lot.
That's how I live.
I eat.
You're so funny.
So she's got a crazy tree with bags on it right now.
Oh yeah.
What a fucking not yeah,
immigrants,
man.
They don't give a fuck.
They do everything crazy style by the way.
Funny salivate.
You have a lot.
I,
there's a strong,
there's a strong backlash against you in the the water championship.
How are we going to fuck up?
Yeah,
I think we should.
Um,
so we put a poll out there.
Oh fuck.
Off to see on these losers.
A bunch of fucking losers.
I answered you.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's over.
Now.
The 69% time,
31% jeans.
Um,
why don't you ask fucking Daniel and your Lincoln Den.
A lot of people feel like you know that you can't be trusted for a number of
reasons.
Here's an,
here's an example.
Uh,
Tom is the best.
He's not a big fat liar.
Like the non main mommy.
Eight oh eight.
Remember that wasn't a lie.
That was just misinformation.
I did not know.
And then deliberately lie,
obviously bigger gulps.
That's cause you're bigger.
You're just a bigger animal than me.
Big,
stupid,
stinky,
dumb bear.
The water champion drinks more water necessarily because you drink less
frequently,
uh,
than I do even though I sit all day.
But how is this even a debate?
The hair?
Is this even a question
Tom was taking bigger steps?
No,
hence what this is the tortoise and the historical evidence.
Your honor,
your honor.
Look at the physical evidence.
Your honor.
This is what's known as a,
it's a long race.
It's a marathon that I run.
Okay.
You do your sprints and I'm in for the long haul.
Bitch.
The tortoise wins says put genes.
Key is the SIP chain,
but pure water intake,
it's buns all day.
Go Fuck yourself and your,
your stupid fucking Twitter followers.
You know what?
I actually feel like I actually feel like maybe,
okay,
maybe you agree with them.
I think you agree with them.
Now I'm not even going to,
I think you maybe
that I am the water champion.
I think you think I'm water champion.
I think here's the evidence.
Are you hydrating after your boxing of at me?
I have two liter and a half of water.
Got To hydrate soldier.
You know,
hydrating isn't just for graduates.
The Florida graduate.
Oh,
people want to hear that
you drink like an animal.
That was one swag for Tommy,
that that amount that you just drank.
And I could never do that in one.
Not In one swoop.
You drink like a bear.
Okay,
so what is,
I just said that now and that's historical.
So what you're saying,
Tom,
you're the water champion.
Did not say that.
I said I could not do that because I'm,
I don't weigh whatever it is.
You and Bert collectively way I don't have the big stomachs like you and Bert.
So you're not drinking enough water.
No,
I am.
I'm just,
it's a slow burn.
What did I tell you?
It's a marathon.
You're sprinting.
That's what fucking dilettante water drinkers do.
Like yourself?
No,
you could never drink as much water.
Well,
let's over the course of a few,
your honor,
maybe a few days.
Let me allow me to introduce my evidence from Twitter.
J at big Jay savage rights.
If Tom had enough water,
he wouldn't be Dj dad mouth.
It's because you're so dehydrated and smelly from drinking coffee and not enough
water.
That's why our Dj Dad mouth.
That's not true.
It's not true.
I'm the water champion.
First of all,
I appreciate you voting me the water champion.
I'll never let you down.
I'll continue to drink far more water seen it could ever drink.
This poll is rigged.
I don't believe for a minute that that the listeners thing at the end of the
day,
your rig at the end of the day though,
who has drank more water,
this is nonsense.
I swear to God I do.
Can I tell you why?
Last night before we went to bed,
I had by my bed stand to full avi-on bottles.
What did you have next to your bed to drink at night,
Tom?
Now you're just showing off.
This is all for the cameras.
You know that he never does this when the cameras are off.
Tom,
how much water did you have next to your bed last night?
I guess it was like a liter and a half.
No wrong.
A tiny little shitty cup.
A mug.
You could never drink as much water.
Okay.
I just had another report and from uh,
someone who went to see you in west Nyack.
Okay.
That Tom didn't drink water at the entire time.
He was on stage and that's at least an hour that had gone by.
No,
it's true.
It's on Twitter versus
well you must be severely dehydrated because you're sweating up there and you're
moving and you do your routine where you pretend to have sex with a stool and
you like Bruce Bruce.
Do you have the towel?
You're always sweating.
I drink so much water after sets.
As soon as I get offstage I drink,
I dunno cause you're dehydrated.
Severely notes from all of the talking.
I'll drink like 16 after a show and people,
those of us that hydrate properly,
consistently throughout the day bring the water on stage.
You need to work on your concession speech.
That's it.
I competed.
I lost.
And your nominee is,
can I send you a photograph?
I sent you a photograph but I'd like to pull it up right now your honor.
Okay.
This is the photo.
That's what you're saying.
That's what the word photograph is.
Shore photo is a shortened version of photograph.
What the fuck is this?
This is a picture of me when I was born.
Could you please pull it up as evidence of what's happening?
What does it show you?
What does I do in the minute I came out of my mother?
What am I doing?
Yeah,
you have what?
You're holding a bottle of water.
This is so unnecessary.
Why?
Graphic evidence?
This is me being born and I already have water in my hand right now.
Don't believe that.
I don't believe it and I'm going to fight this verdict.
You're fucking Bernie Sanders right now.
I have the nomination.
You're George Bush.
No,
I have the vote.
I have the votes.
This is Florida.
I demand a recount are in.
I demand a recount.
This is the Chad.
This is a hanging Chad.
I don't know who these people are and it doesn't.
There's not enough water.
That's you.
That's you right now I will give you this puny fake Twitter fan.
Loser.
Victory.
Fake.
The the,
the voting.
No,
that was,
that was real.
I don't care.
Listen,
I was like 1200 people but 1200 listen,
I'll give you your stupid loser Twitter poll.
Like everybody,
1,348 votes.
You lost by it a lot.
Okay?
You know what?
I'll give you this bullshit victory today.
Why is it a bullshit Vic?
Cause it's fucking wrong bro.
You don't know the truth bomb.
You know why you're a fucking loser.
You drink water with losers.
Okay.
At least I drink wine.
I don't know where your office is locked up.
This is all for show guys.
His his bullshit water jug.
Which blue band picked up for you on the way in?
Don't think I don't fucking notice that because I,
that shit was cold.
It wasn't in our fridge.
No,
it wasn't in our fridge.
Not True.
Hello?
I always ask who gets the Sparkletts in the house?
Who makes sure that shows up?
Who orders bottled water so that you can hydrate properly.
So sad to see somebody just
treading water that they can't drink.
There's a video.
I have a view in west Nyack.
This is for now to,
okay,
well I'm just letting you know that someone saw you in west Nyack and they took
it again.
They took footage of you.
He didn't know you were being watched.
Okay,
here we go.
Tom,
why you that lady's car?
I want this lady.
I've never said this,
but I want her to get eaten by a bear so badly.
She's trying to reason with the bear.
This is the most part.
If that camera could of kept rolling and he'd just devoured her mind.
That funny documentary we watched hilarious dot Timothy Treadwell.
That's right.
That's how I know you and I would be married,
but it was retarded you.
When I went to see that documentary when we were just dating and the Timothy
Treadwell,
what was it called?
Grizzly man.
And we saw it in the theaters.
Narrator,
the director.
I remember the German got Santa hats on down now.
And there is a part where the guy goes,
yeah,
we thought we just thought Timothy was retarded and you and I laughed out loud
together and no one else,
no one else lives here.
And when he got mall,
we were dating.
It was a dating period.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I was like this guy,
the whole time he was talking about it and so many bears on that,
like he'd make those videos were like,
this is fucking down.
And then Verna was like,
there was a special connection,
no Canadian in the bank.
The connection was the bear was going to eat you this guy.
He was like,
yeah,
this is my little Fox Fox.
He had one of those things like a fucking eight year old woman that gets a bird
and calls it like Birdie,
you know,
this is bear bear box.
He so dumb.
He was living on a bare reserve and he thought he was protecting the bears.
Frog will fight for these barriers.
It was a crazy person.
Totally agree.
Yeah.
Being out with dangerous bears and then he got eaten by them.
What a shocker.
Yeah.
Big Dummy.
Big fucking dummy hanging out with losers and he got eaten by them.
Absolutely.
Um,
let's get into this real quick.
A update on Burton and
his fatness.
God,
no.
So never,
never.
It just keeps morphing into something better.
You know,
we owe it to the listeners and everybody to play a lot,
uh,
of Bert.
Yeah.
You know,
people think that we're,
you know,
we're best buddies,
man.
I think people need to know that this is not a one sided things.
Right.
We're bringing you the other side of the coin.
Here's Burt on a,
hey Jay hawks podcast,
the hot cast,
uh,
Kinda filling him in on,
on some of this stuff.
Incompetence.
I tell him I'm the fattest I've ever been getting.
Buns shares that with everybody.
God dammit.
Burt looks like Gerard.
Depardieu so to be,
that's right.
That was a few months ago.
But to be fair,
I want to say this.
He did not say in confidence.
He started making videos.
I'm the fattest I've ever been.
Right.
It was public about it and he was weighing himself on,
like weighing himself on videos.
Yeah.
Sang that.
So it wasn't,
that's the bird has a way of twisting,
you know?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was making,
I'm so fat,
trying to lose weight.
My agent called at one point it was like,
hey,
you're trending right behind Kesha and Amy Schumer and fat shaming.
Okay,
Georgia might,
my 12 girl pulled me aside and goes,
Daddy,
people say really mean things to you online and I go,
baby,
it's not real.
It's not.
The Internet's not real.
I go in my head,
I'm like,
I go there.
My fans too,
but then part of me is like RNA.
Okay,
no.
Here's the thing.
Here's the thing you can do right now is I am overweight like I am.
The second fatness I'd ever been in my life.
The second by second bedroom.
Oh,
only second to the time I told Tom Campaign,
oh man,
she's a hammer and booster.
Like Liam's got a lot of one that's like bird looks dark.
Gerard Gerard Depardieu.
Apparently we have some similarities.
Remember that naked?
It was a nude photo,
nude photo where they,
they did look,
he has a similar bloated,
distended,
swollen.
Now Gerard is a little bit bigger.
I'll give him that,
but not by much,
but now by a lot,
maybe five pounds.
I'm six feet.
You're six one like that kind of thing.
Yeah,
I think they put the meme together.
Would it put your face on his bottom?
And
there are barely a lot of fat babies that look a lot like
God.
It's Co,
you know,
Tom and I find it more funny than not,
especially when like a publicist is like,
hey,
you're not getting a lot of good feedback on the show.
And I was like,
really?
She's like,
all anyone can tell yourself that
is they don't technically fat shame the fattest people,
big fat shame.
The people who were on the fence of like notes happened.
No one really says it to me,
but he's not just talking about us.
I think he's talking about fat shaming.
People get fat shamed on the cusp of obesity or people who you know,
shouldn't be fat.
That's how it goes.
I mean,
that's all the stuff.
Like when I get,
I've got,
uh,
a lot of fat comments over the years and people who are like,
you're a piece of shit.
You should be,
you shouldn't be this fat.
Not like you're 400 pounds.
They're just like stop being lazy.
Cases that are like well into four or 500 people,
you're dying.
You don't see people bombard those people because they already feel like shit
and I imagine when you're,
that big shit goes down and I just want to eat.
That's a guy who doesn't get it.
Why are you,
what are you talking about?
I want to get this to stop it.
I want to get skinnier than Tom.
I am skinnier than he is not.
He is not skinny in good shape.
Oh my God.
Everyone who was here and I go,
hey,
we weighed the same.
Does it look different?
He's,
yeah,
he's in such good shape.
He's never been out of shape.
You know what I mean?
That's a lifetime of never being out of shape.
Does Burt actually way,
like what do you,
what are you guessing?
What do I think he was?
I Dunno.
Three.
I don't know.
Boys weights now probably three ten three times.
You're putting all this morning now.
I feel bad.
I don't know if many people,
I haven't heard much from him.
He had me do a little promo.
Wait,
look at Birch reaction when he finds out though.
This is the best.
So you're putting all this,
I mean,
now I feel bad.
I don't know if any people I haven't heard much from,
he had me do a little promo
for Chrysler.
Chrysler burnt.
Yeah.
There's more,
sorry,
how old is age?
He's probably 32.
33.
Did they look amazing?
Yeah.
You keep saying,
you know why I keep saying that in relation to bloated alcoholic bird is what
I'm saying.
No,
of course he looks amazing.
He's a professional athlete.
He's right.
But that's
clean living,
that's not drinking wine and like being in like,
he,
you know,
started playing sports probably like in,
elementary school.
Right.
And literally at the 32 year old man has never stopped.
Wow.
That's being like on sports teams.
Like,
yeah.
Just,
uh,
just,
it never ended up,
that's what I'm saying.
Remember in highlights magazine?
Goofus and gallant.
Yeah.
One's doing the wrong thing.
Oh yeah.
That's definitely this.
Yeah.
And it's so apparent who's doing the right thing here.
Oh,
it's all,
yeah,
yeah.
That latest blog he did was so damn funny.
There's a moment if even go to is I didn't give it to his youtube page,
Thompson era.
There's a moment where he gets on a scale,
just looks download scammy goes 200.
Oh,
you guys should watch that blog.
It's great blue boy.
Or is it a shot and edited?
It's on Tom Cigarettes.
Go to Youtube,
uh,
into the Thomson [inaudible] Youtube page.
Hilarious.
I said to my therapist,
I go,
if I had a nickel for every time.
I said,
it's a joke guys.
It's a joke now you say it so much that you start going,
is it a joke?
Is this a joke?
Are they my fam?
They are,
I think it's loud.
People love them.
Some people was,
look,
I've gotten a little bit of the reversal,
so people are really cutting and like me and you're like,
Jesus.
You know?
Yeah.
I've gotten a few of those,
but most people are kind of clever.
This is what comics do.
They shit on each other all the time.
This is part of the,
it's,
it doesn't mean anything.
Not yet
called me.
And he goes,
he goes,
hey man,
I gotta do something because I really,
I'm starting to feel bad.
And I go,
don't,
I go,
Tom,
don't do any,
I can't have you.
It'll make it a mouse.
I can't have you come out the front door.
What?
I'm going to fight with my mom and an apron and be like,
guys,
split it up or I'm going to have to call your mom,
you know?
And so I go,
Tom,
this has,
I go,
we've got to take this to the end.
And you got to ride this all the way to the fucking ground.
And if it means our careers,
it means our fucking weird.
We're taking this all the way,
right?
I did.
I felt bad.
But then there's,
yeah.
And my only goal right now is to beat Tom,
is to be skinnier than Tom.
Oh Wow.
Is that really,
you think he's really gonna how long do you think that's going to last until he
goes on the road again?
Oh Man.
And then he has to drink.
Well,
he never is off the road,
so I'll always stay ahead of them.
Of course.
Cause even like,
of course I'm on the road and you know,
my,
I tell you my regimen,
like I call you,
I go,
Oh,
you know,
I got the show in a few hours going to the gym.
Yeah.
Spend like an hour there,
shower.
It's never going to,
that takes discipline.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
that's a FIFO dreaming.
He also went on punch drunk and uh,
it was really funny with Jason.
Jason Tebow.
Yeah.
And uh,
he had some pretty funny things there.
Every has like a running
gags and running jokes.
So I didn't know crab feast.
I did,
I don't know what this was,
but everyone was like,
hey,
please ask Bert,
why are you so fat and that maybe I got 50 of them.
Please ask Bert Way.
He's so fan.
And then Tom was like,
hey man,
I really am sorry.
Like I didn't mean for it to get this big.
And then I was like,
he didn't mean for that to get that bigger you to get that bit
hilarious.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Just thank God and I go and don't ever forget your fucking fatter than me.
That's the funniest part of the whole thing is Tom is like do 70 to 80.
No Way am not.
I am at least 30 pounds lighter than bull.
No Way.
And by the way,
no way.
Even even with those numbers aside,
body composition wise.
Yes,
I agree.
You know Burt's got that hard fat belly.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
That's a different balance.
He's got this amazing self esteem.
Unbelievable.
Like the fact that I have friends pulled me aside going,
I don't think you're fat when clearly I fucking am like the second fattest I've
ever been.
Nope.
But I have friends pulled me aside going,
I don't think you're fat when clearly I fucking am.
Okay.
Um,
yeah.
So there's a couple more things I want to play,
but obviously he's also admitting that he's very right.
Yeah.
Well,
birds never had a problem admitting that he's mad.
I know he's always known it and then ignored whatever steps to take to,
to not be so fat.
Right.
You know,
there's pictures of him.
That's what I shot.
My Special Ed was two 35.
Okay.
And,
but shirtless and oddly enough,
still very overweight.
This is the band is that in the midst of this bird is fat campaign.
He's going to have a special come out where he's shirt.
Right.
Oh,
that's going to be great.
I mean there's,
look,
I won't even mention it when that happens,
but it's going to explode.
Yeah.
Like shed a bunch of pallets to be,
his body will never lose weight.
He does not have that kind of body that the weight will just,
that's not trail.
That'll never happen.
Whose only goal is to turn into a power lifter and just get bigger.
Okay.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
what was I saying before you really interrupts me?
I forgot,
I'm sorry.
I completely forgot my thought.
I'm sorry Tom.
Like we go out to eat and you just watch Benji do.
Oh,
he fucking murderers.
Food Israeli.
Oh yeah,
he's,
he bought her stuff.
I've never heard of like why I use the first person that introduced me to this
is makes me laugh so hard is his impression of me is so far off.
Yeah.
But his commitment to it is amazing.
Squid Pasta.
Oh.
He was like,
we went to his place.
He's like,
no,
no.
You've got to get the ink squid bots a little bit of a little bit shaved.
Uh,
uh,
what are the mushrooms?
Trussell's truffles,
truffle tremor troubles are going to love it all.
And I was like,
really?
He was like,
oh,
it wasn't fucking greatest.
Same.
Get one of those.
You know what we're going to get?
Let me just run it for you.
And then he just orders two things.
He wants him throwing you under the bus by ordering you a bunch of fatty foods
we can keep shitting on.
You know,
this was a while ago.
We went out to every time we've gone out to eat,
he just thought,
I murder booze.
He murders.
Okay.
Can I,
can I finish that sentence?
He should say I murder booze.
He murders food.
I also murder food.
Yes,
he eats so much sound like it's so much faster than anybody I've ever seen in my
life.
In inhales his plate by the time I'm in one bite.
That's why he thinks other people are murdering food.
Yeah.
Is Gone.
I know.
Remember when we went out with the Chrysler's right before I delivered Ellis?
Yeah.
Literally like a week before.
Yes.
And there's a video of it.
The blog of course.
Go ahead and look at birds like yeah,
he orders.
So five entrees for himself.
Yeah.
And then orders all the desserts and he,
it like two bites and then bottles of wine.
Yeah.
Every one of every dessert.
I'm not even exaggerating.
Yeah.
Go ahead and let me look at birds.
He keeps me,
he's not a big drinker.
He'll have like a glass of wine,
like a woman.
And then I will drink w I'll go get a bottle and they'll go,
yeah,
yeah.
And then it'd be like my wife,
I give them a glass,
I drink the rest of the bottle and then he orders,
well,
you know what,
we just got a couple deserves.
So we'll just go get two forks and then you're like,
oh God.
And then he just was like,
that'll order three key lime pie who don't want to kill it.
But I don't think calories,
I don't even like sweets.
So he just eats them all.
Oh Wow.
God,
look at,
look at birds Vlog.
He's to look at it when he go hard.
When we all went out to dinner when I was like about to pop.
Yeah.
And it'll,
it'll show you let the record show that led to register order five desserts,
burnt Chrysler burned Chrysler ordered five desserts,
five bottles of wine and 10 entrees.
I'm real this guy.
Could we,
I think we should really set up some sort of comedy battle royal.
Like Ari was saying,
no salmon are you are going to fight.
I didn't know that,
but we might be able to get an undercard of you and they're going to box.
What are you talking about?
Why do they have beef?
I think so,
but like,
yeah,
like,
like people don't know that burnt and I don't have any beef and there's no
animosity.
No.
Zero could we,
I think we should really set up some sort of comedy battle royal.
Like Ari was saying,
no salmon,
Ari are going to fight,
but we might be able to get an undercard you and Segura maybe just a half
rounder before you both have fucking heart attack
heavier than I am.
But I'd be afraid to,
cause it's like so much foundation there.
You know,
like he's just thick.
Like I'm a light frisky to third 40 he's like,
God,
he's like a solid two side.
Like you can't move that.
He is the mountain and I'm the young gay guy that dances around and almost
winning.
Yeah,
he's right though.
Your meat and cheese.
You're solid bear on this year on your way.
So what about,
what about a j hawk?
Yep.
Oh,
he was like,
yeah,
I feel bad.
I'm gonna cut some promos for sucker on about how fat you are.
Really.
I go are you should be
two steps ahead of me in all of this.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well he's got time to do.
He's also playing it like a gay man.
I'm going to call off the dogs.
You're good.
And he's cutting promos with aging,
allowing burden into a false sense of security.
Huh?
The best.
Yeah.
I had a four egg omelet before I came here to hear it.
Like,
yeah,
I got,
I got two hungry.
So anyways,
the bird is fat stuff.
Look,
I don't even push it anymore.
I'm just giving you the updates.
The main thing I wanted people to know because I feel like it's not understood
by some,
most people get it,
is that that there's no animosity that we are really good friends.
We talk almost every day.
But people sometimes they get comms for people that are like,
whoa man.
Like I can't believe like why are you pulling him?
I'm like,
it's called comedy world.
Yeah.
So anyways,
um,
yeah.
By the way,
we've had a,
you know what?
I gotta take a Piss.
I've had so much water.
Oh,
that's probably because you're not used to drinking so much water.
No,
it's because it's so much more water than you'll ever drink in a week.
And I just had it in like 30 minutes.
Why don't you share the back of your neck too funny.
You Talk Shit and then you went and peed yourself.
Well that's because I thought I should,
but I didn't have to go as badly as you did because you're obviously showboating
and it's not normal for you to drink this much water.
There's totally no color.
Was it?
What do you think?
It's always just the color wall.
Shit I've smelled or as,
you're such a liar.
I can't even believe it.
I swear.
I wish I had smellovision when you and I shower together and you pee and it's
out.
Was Dark
Brown like the coffee and it's smells of cough on Hobos.
Shower,
shower.
It's every time you shower with me,
you're so disgusting.
I swear to God this one wire and you're a liar.
Anyways,
so this morning you made an explosion smoothie.
Well,
I should credit and I regrettably don't remember his name,
the chef at wet nap sack.
Really Nice Guy.
He knows you.
He remembered you.
Oh yeah.
He's real friendly and he's like,
there's only a few clubs were like the chef will come in the green room.
Be like anything you want.
That's so nice.
So nice healthy eater.
I'm like burnt Chrysler.
You probably were like,
feel so welcoming.
And so you know,
there's,
there's a few kitchens like that first night I ordered this chicken dish was
great.
And then actually a lot of people were even tweeting me that there they were
like,
we actually have it working at a club where the food is good cause it's nice,
really good food there.
Anyways.
Then somebody else mentioned it,
they're like,
oh if you had one of those smoothies and I didn't know what they meant.
I thought they were talking about something sweet,
you know,
like what kind of smoothie?
Oh he just throws a bunch of fruits and vegetables and I go,
oh I'll try that.
Because I had just literally on the road I tried to maintain this thing where I
go work out shower show.
Right.
You know,
because if you,
if you do it in that order,
it's a,
it's a good time of day.
Do you started at?
Well,
let's say I have a seven o'clock show,
I will try to work out,
uh,
between four 45.
I'll try,
I'll try to start in the gym between four 45 and five.
That way you have like a good,
however long you want to work out,
30 40,
60 minutes and then you're not rushed.
So you,
you go back to your room,
you take a shower,
you can do,
you don't have to rush there.
She knew casually before shows anymore.
That's old.
No.
What happens is those workouts give you that energy boost that cause a lot of
times if you drag,
you feel lethargic on the road.
Yeah.
But if you go to,
if you do your workout right before take your shower,
you get dressed,
you kind of feel like,
oh,
I'm really like awake right now.
Alive.
Yes.
Alive and energized.
And then you arrive at the show.
I also like to get picked up very late.
Yeah.
So that I can arrive.
I don't want to wait at the,
at the nine years.
So I do that,
I arrive and then at showtime and it feels great.
Um,
but the only thing that becomes kind of hairy then is if you had worked out,
you're going to go to your show,
you get hungry,
you don't want to eat a lot of times comedy club food.
So this option,
the smoothie,
I was like,
this is excellent.
Anyways,
I asked him what he,
what he,
how he makes it and he tells me,
you know,
cucumbers,
lime juice.
Uh,
he goes,
you don't have that.
Maybe if you don't have the cucumber,
you use Kale and avocado apples and just,
it's just a mix.
Mash of like of fruits and vegetables.
Right.
So I just asked you to pick it up while I was gone.
I fired it up this morning for you.
And
right away,
first of all,
I did the,
um,
cause it was the first time making it,
I did the taste test.
I go,
let me see what it tastes like.
After two sips of taste test I got,
I gotta take a shit that was two sips.
Yeah.
Explosion came back,
uh,
added a little soy milk water.
We didn't have ice,
so to make a call to put cold water in there.
And then,
um,
gave you,
you had about what,
three quarters of it?
I saw you as a little bit,
you gave me a nice healthy tall glass and here I am like,
yeah,
this,
this tastes great.
It's going down super easy.
I'm feeding.
The kid were laughing and then we take Ellis up for his nap,
his morning nap.
And I'm like,
well why don't you put them down?
I,
my stomach hurts a little bit and I had already taken my morning shit.
I drink my coffee in the morning,
I shit.
And then she usually it for the day.
I don't,
we'll shit anymore.
But I felt a rumbling and I was like,
I gotta go.
You never do two in the morning?
Yeah.
And the pain,
the cramping,
I was doubled over and I was like whole Mike.
God,
it was a six,
a hot six.
Yeah.
But now I just shower immediately.
And by the way,
the day it wasn't enough.
It was back to shit to shower because of this.
Wow.
Now did you discover that because you use per day wiped and then you're like
this isn't enough.
Yeah,
so I a date it.
I read brainstorming sprints,
brainstorm insurance.
I left it extra long and I went to wipe and there was still brown on the paper.
Ah.
And I go,
it's time for old school.
What a story now do you think now you don't think obviously that what I made
was,
was bad.
What do you think is,
it's just so intense.
It's not bad.
What did it,
what it is is you've got your Kale and then you put like 10 lines in lime juice
alone will make me shit apples.
I saw you throw in apples I saw is high,
high,
high fibrous and you need something like a banana to pull it together cause
there's nothing on yogurt or something to pull it because it's all like high
fiber,
high acidic,
orange.
You had orange in there too.
So I mean eating one orange alone will make me shit dynamite like already.
Yeah,
it's gotta be tempered jeans.
You hear me?
How should I have done?
Okay.
Here's what I would do if I were you.
Half a banana,
a little bit of Yogurt,
like Greek yogurt.
You do,
you're a like a peach.
Maybe some stores,
some berries,
blueberries,
strawberry and maybe some Kale and cucumber.
And that's it.
You can't do all acidic fibrous.
I mean,
sorry,
we what?
Okay,
I'll,
uh,
I'll tone it down.
I'll go pick up the banana is going to help because the banana binds it.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
There's a lot that was really intense.
I think I lost weight though.
Today's my weigh in day on weight watchers.
So you'll look great.
I do,
you know why discipline,
I don't need anymore.
I just stopped eating
at night.
I don't eat at night.
I stopped eating by five o'clock.
I try not to eat.
I try not to drink a lot too,
but I got to say it was different,
you know,
it was,
it was still a morning sort of explosion,
but it was,
it was a healthier one.
I felt good.
When are you going to see the doctor for this IBS?
This is week.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
I wish we could live tweet the event.
Maybe blue.
Can I come with you and live tweet?
What is it Tommy?
Are you afraid you missed your appointment?
I don't want to miss my appointment.
Is it today or tomorrow?
It's Thursday.
Okay.
Yeah.
What are you looking at?
What?
Nothing.
I'm just thinking about it.
That's all you are.
You're excited to go to the doctor for your IBS.
Of course.
Are they going to make you shit?
They're like we have to bring in a stool sample.
Um,
like with Theo and we have to take dogs.
Might be,
he might be getting to know you kind of sit down.
Oh right.
Tell him all the brown stores.
What did he goes away about what you're going through.
And I go,
could you just download a few episodes of your mind?
Can I tell you something though?
You need to start making I shit diary and a diet diary so this guy can have a
good picture.
Okay.
Cause you have,
and I don't mean this in a mean way,
kind of a skewed memory about what happens to you because you don't really put
cause and effect together very well.
The,
you're saying that like I'm a,
a patient who maybe doesn't have all his yes.
Brain cells working.
Cause you do the same thing over and over and then you get diarrhea.
And I have to be like,
Babe,
you can't have fried food.
It makes you shit.
Hmm.
You're such a show off.
You're such a show off right now.
You're not even that thirsty.
You're just doing this for the cameras.
They can't even see the truth.
This is such fucking bullshit.
Are you done?
That's one step.
But you do that like twice a day,
but you don't understand what it is to be the water champion.
I consume so much water.
Okay.
Can we talk about something else?
Sure.
Um,
we got,
uh,
a request on Youtube from,
Oh my,
are you ready?
Yes.
Nick Hawk.
She wanted to get us on the copyright infringement and say that we're playing a
song as it,
it should be taken down.
Isn't that amazing.
He didn't like that.
We weren't talking about his music.
His music.
Yeah.
It was very upset.
And guess what?
We fought the law and we won.
Well,
we didn't really fight it.
No,
he didn't.
So we just didn't get taken down because there's no infringement.
Yeah.
We didn't infringe.
We explored and discussed it and gave him credit for his horrible,
horrible music.
Yeah.
I mean,
he actually filed the copyright claim.
This is what they wrote back to us.
If it was a few episodes ago,
where right.
We played some of his songs.
Um,
let me,
uh,
let's play them again just for old time's sake.
Well,
I,
cause I feel like they're all so terrible,
but then what's the most terrible Nick Kok Song?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well,
you know.
Yeah.
What's the most unpleasant STD?
They're all pretty bad dude.
Yeah,
I bet he was.
What's the worst Steven Seagal movie?
They're all pretty terrible,
but that's what you're asking when you're asking what's the worst?
Nick hawks,
his,
his album is really,
really atrocious.
So
here is a,
but it's the best worst.
So it is the best.
Worst though,
by the way,
a lot of people didn't go to it.
They didn't really try it out.
And then,
I mean,
it says here's the comments under it.
Hey,
Mommy's checking in high and tight here.
Um,
you should stick to fucking old white women really over it looks like he hasn't
found the come low and Louis no common.
These balls
thought it was pretty good.
High and tight.
Just like my jeans got a fan.
Okay.
We're not just discouraging people from becoming a fan.
Breaking a sweat.
So
gets,
what's the
catch up?
I take off like a jet.
I mean,
yeah,
it sounds he's just behind Kendrick Lamar.
They were both very talented.
Um,
is that,
is that your favorite?
That's my favorite song is yes,
it is.
Okay.
My favorite intentionally awesome song.
Uh,
yeah,
there's a bunch of,
what else can read me?
The titles I've forgotten,
which is my favorite.
He's got one that's called,
everybody's got a little country in him.
I didn't know that.
Sounds like a new jam.
Let's give it a listen.
Maybe it's better.
I thought it was
a rapper.
No matter where you,
no matter what.
This is Nick Hodge from the Kong.
Great.
That's actually really good,
nick.
Yeah,
stick to country.
That's the thing.
You're just in the wrong lane.
Yeah.
Your accidental song.
It's good.
Good.
I like this a lot better.
There's a little cottage.
Hey,
this is actually good.
Good job.
Wow.
Job.
Here's another one called,
yeah,
forget the rabbit.
I mean that guy,
Vince.
No issue on the rap battle.
We saw that episode on Juggalos and look,
there's nothing wrong with saying this isn't my genre,
this isn't my lane.
Pick something you're good at and here's a great country,
Dan.
You know,
I'm happy in,
yeah,
I still like breaking a sweat.
The vest I d I think that's still my favorite worst,
best,
worst song of Nick Hodge.
He's got a music video.
I like how your eyes just looked at the screen,
please.
Okay,
So there's a [inaudible] thank I've been waiting for a video.
Yeah.
Didn't know that he had a good Yo.
Oh Shit
I've ever seen in my life.
I don't.
You describe it.
What's going on for it?
I don't think I can't describe it without being embarrassed.
Can you?
Yeah,
it's called we fight.
Um,
and it begins by him
walking and it looked like a in the desert.
What?
Twirling a sword or some fighting instrument in a,
in a manner that a martial arts expert would.
Right.
And now he's walking around a fire shirtless and shirtless.
This is very to Sigale by them.
I'm predicting he ends up fighting himself.
That's what we're going to see.
That there's going to be two people and that they're both,
yeah,
it's always about him,
right?
Yeah.
Bye.
Why do you shoot it on an iPhone?
You can tell right away that like the video quality city.
God Damn it man.
I know.
At least rent a decent fucking camera.
Your fucking money on it.
Gotcha.
Tore always and just use some of that whole money.
None.
It's too dark.
You can't even see ya.
You gotta hire a grip.
You need a lighting.
Yeah.
Come on Bro.
What are you fucking knew the sound,
the song sound very similar like one with the exception of the country song.
And it also sounds like the last song.
Okay,
well I'm done.
I'm too distracted.
Isn't a Geeky,
and he's chopping,
you know,
different blue posturing and now he's in a jacket and he's saying we fight.
Yeah.
So
did he give so much ink on that one arm,
shoulder,
chest,
and shorten shoulder that it's just all black.
Now does Steven Seagal make music?
Yes.
Oh,
the harmonica.
Or was that Burrito plays the blues.
Right.
And,
and,
and he sings,
right?
Steven does like,
is it good?
Like is he,
is he okay?
Is it Steven Seagal better at singing the Nick Hawkins at scene?
Yes,
very much.
Bye.
We fight my which way and carry too much weight and keeping it,
keeping noxious.
Let's just see if he embarrassed.
I want to see if he fight some.
Okay.
How's it going to fight?
This he doing is working out here going,
of course.
That's what he does.
He works out.
He twirls the sword.
Oh Shit.
Now he's on a rock and he's,
he's on a rock.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh,
well how much are you,
and it's an iPhone shooting.
He's on a rock.
He's spreading his wings.
Uh,
what is happening?
I'm so super,
he has the behavior of somebody really into coke,
but I don't think he does it.
You know,
there's a lot of coke had behavior.
I know,
I know.
I know you're talking about like create,
Sean was Kinda like this.
Oh yeah.
We'll just twirling.
He never fights anybody.
He just twirls wrong.
He,
he did well.
It's kind of 94,000 views.
I was a lot of use.
Good.
Nick.
Um,
let's see.
They released,
it was released
February.
Wow.
Good for him.
This song is honestly so cringe worthy.
Read some other reviews.
Let me see.
You did it again.
Great job.
Uh Huh.
Uh,
it's like rich Vos,
his son decided to smoke weed and not give a care.
Needs more Skype punches all inner game on that.
Yeah.
He does need a crazy low cause to help him.
Great job.
I like the constant changing of the backgrounds.
Oof.
Yeah.
Extremely passionate on many levels.
Oh,
that's good.
That's positive.
That is accurate.
Love it.
And you were smoking hot.
There you go.
Okay.
Love it.
Amazing.
Can't wait to jam out to this feeling it.
I love your voice.
You're definitely more than just a pretty face.
Is this a guy?
An older man that's,
that's a woman fierce.
That's,
that's how I would best describe it.
You have to,
yeah.
Fierce.
We fight.
I'm digging it.
Great job.
You got a lot of love.
God.
Dagon maybe we're wrong.
Maybe this,
uh,
you know,
this could be a huge hit.
Could be,
man.
I don't know.
It hasn't been up that long.
You've got about a hundred thousand of years.
Yeah.
A lot of it.
So maybe,
maybe I'm not the music aficionado.
I thought I was.
Yeah,
you're always,
I mean,
to be fair,
I've never said that.
I understand music that well,
but Christina definitely does.
Definitely get on her.
Sure.
He hit on me.
Yeah.
If,
like I'm saying,
if you're mad no,
no.
At,
at Tom Cigarette,
let him know how you feel.
Um,
but hey,
good attempt.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We can't all be breaking a sweat.
He'll probably copyright claim this episode too.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's a price you pay for greatness.
Well look man,
we're,
you know,
we're putting his name out there.
Yeah.
Is there any actually that giving you more attention,
which is a good thing.
I'll put my city,
you know,
and show business.
Any,
any publicity is good publicity.
So,
yeah.
You know.
Yeah.
This is a highly powerful show listening to.
We've had
Gloria,
Stefan on,
uh,
Brendon Urie of panic at the disco listens to our show.
We a lot of celebrities,
Rogen your mate brace,
brace on multiple times,
multiple times.
We are huge Braves fan.
Yeah.
So there you go.
That's grace.
Um,
jeans.
Yeah,
there's always uh,
uh,
you know what I'm saying is that you want to keep track of yeah.
This man's actually been in before,
but he has a new appearance.
Okay.
And I think he wanted to Trump his last appearance because his new,
you know what I'm saying?
Count is out of control.
Is Dj Khaled,
uh,
the keys of life.
Um,
he was on chemo and a check to,
Oh shit,
I'm already fucking up.
You can see,
I can see is live saying,
you know what I'm saying?
Like it.
Camel has to be like,
uh Huh.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It was saying and you'll say no,
sadly,
you know,
saying,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
And this is by the way,
obviously one sit down.
Yeah.
Sometimes these things are over.
Like,
you know,
a guy's getting interviewed in the studio.
It might be an hour long.
Six,
five minutes.
Yeah.
Well actually I want to snapchat the whole birth.
Oh saying know what I'm saying?
You I'm saying,
Oh,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm saying what I'm saying.
You know what I'm saying?
What I'm saying?
I'm saying like,
I know what you're saying.
You know what I'm saying?
You got the keys,
you know,
saying what's this gentleman's name?
Dj Khaled.
I would say per time,
this might be the champion in terms like he did
breakfast club,
[inaudible] morning radio show in New York.
[inaudible] and his,
you know what I'm saying is were just outrageous.
Yeah.
But it was also like an hour.
Okay.
So that's what I'm saying.
Uh,
you know what I'm saying?
You were saying,
Yeah.
Is it for the time ratio too?
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
The high level high volume here,
high volt,
this is a contender for the most,
you know what I'm saying,
is in the shortest amount of time I would say yeah.
Uh hmm.
Yes.
Quantity in time.
Wow.
That was a really good one.
I'm very impressive.
It's very impressive.
Hmm.
So,
um,
now the funniest one,
there's a funniest,
you know what I'm saying?
The most,
you know what I'm saying is in the shortest amount of time,
yeah,
there's,
it's,
it's an ongoing,
you know,
you can never actually,
you'll never actually really when I know what I'm saying,
but the whole idea is that you,
uh,
I keep telling a,
licking the mic,
my mouth keeps touching it.
Oh.
Uh,
what's your favorite?
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
my favorite,
you know what I'm saying?
I Dunno.
There's a few,
I mean it's,
it's hard to just label one.
Um,
I say I'm done life together pretty great.
Yeah.
One of my favorites is the,
the,
the Japanese one,
you don't fine.
Oh,
right,
right.
You like hip hop Yo.
Yeah.
Thang
no
know,
y'all know.
That's a great way.
And you,
you guys your mouth by repeating a center.
What's your name?
She doesn't know what you sang
to
put it together.
I had it like this like two years.
Yeah.
This rob guy,
he's always great.
Yeah.
Which I was at the helm.
What Mitch?
I'm saying.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Mutual Holdings.
Good motherfucker right there.
You know what I'm saying?
So,
you know what I'm saying?
He's like,
Oh fuck.
With the real,
you know what I'm saying?
So yeah.
Real recognize,
real game.
Recognize game.
What I'm saying ain't no bus.
He goes,
he goes off on the play.
My favorite one.
Oh,
you know the best one.
I know,
but uh,
I don't think I have it queued up though.
Okay.
Um,
yeah.
The,
the best one is a man I never right.
Yeah.
My best in terms of funniest,
I don't mean an in quantity.
Yeah.
This guy might be the v Champ for as many,
you know what I'm saying is in a shortest time,
especially on the television to on the camel,
that this is a huge platform for,
you know what I'm saying?
It is outrageous.
This isn't just like some radio shows off fear though.
This is my,
this is my favorite one stuff here.
Okay.
Check it out.
And you know what I'm saying?
It's a fear.
You know what I'm saying?
Shout out to my main boss,
man.
You know,
he was good.
He's triples up at the top.
Yeah.
Great.
Who was that one was,
who is that?
There's a few of those though.
It's hard to,
he talks about holding in his,
uh,
he not,
not blogging before a game.
Oh,
all right.
That came in more recently.
Kimbo Kimbo yeah,
that was a good one to your right.
Yeah.
Rest in peace.
Oh,
he's dead.
He died a couple weeks ago.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Half 42.
How did he die?
Heart attack?
I think so.
Yeah.
Oh Damn.
And I didn't know that.
Yeah,
I'm super bombed.
I go super funny.
Wow.
Yeah.
42.
That's what sucks about being 40 now is like I could die.
Yeah.
I mean most people don't,
but now motherfuckers are dying and we're already,
you know what I mean?
It happened then people were like,
yeah,
that's just the way it goes.
Yeah.
And now if I die,
it's like not a big,
do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah.
People give it a go.
I don't know what you're saying.
What does it mean?
Right,
right.
Know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
So a brand new case of foreign accent syndrome has come about.
My favorite disease,
um,
it's one of the Oh gee topics of our show.
And you may remember the first time we ever
later
Brianna,
that is a British woman who woke up one day with foreign accent syndrome and now
it is attacking a woman in Texas.
You know what accident she woke up with jeans?
What?
British.
Oh,
cool.
Yeah,
let's hear it.
Well,
people who've met me before,
they shot first and then most people say,
oh,
I love it.
But for me it's a lot different.
Wow.
Listening to this mother,
you think she was from London but uh,
she was actually born and raised right here in Texas.
Strange but true.
And it's an extremely rare case called foreign accent syndrome.
But doctor say it actually happens and now actually happened to try to get her
normal speech.
There's like 15 cases worldwide report is so rare.
It's like a double pipe class for language as paper logs.
Oh,
not from England.
Sorry.
He is 100% Texas painful.
Who Don't know me that,
hey,
where are you from?
Oh wait,
where's that?
I'm like,
Oh,
you talk like that.
So that's when the whole story comes up.
I don't buy this.
Do you buy this?
There was the one that was fake.
Remember the fake one that was clearly fake?
We played it a long time ago.
This lady claimed that she had it and then she walked,
the camera came and he saw her walking in the parking lot.
They stopped her talk to her and then when she walked away she walked sideways.
Like she was doing a little bit of a,
an app cause she said it was a whole neurological thing.
And I tend to think that these people need attention.
It might just be bored and wants some attention.
But it does happen though,
right?
I mean,
I don't know.
Oh,
you're saying you don't believe it at all?
I don't know.
The,
the one,
the one lady who and four year now that one,
she legitimately was a bit tortured by it.
She seemed towards me.
She was like,
I just want,
I want to talk the way I used tall,
tall.
She was like that.
She's like,
she really was.
She was like,
yeah,
I'll watch the way I use that to talk them or she talking like that.
That's how she said it.
She said she did.
So you do it.
You're the master of accents.
Do her doing the accent.
I challis voice in the conversation and combine nearly for Ya know,
for,
you know,
mom is probably the one word I noticed right away on kitten.
They think I'm talking about a baby cat and I'm not.
I'm saying I'm just kidding.
But it's kidding.
I'm just kidding.
But how would she have mastered the
accent?
I mean she's,
she's watching TV,
man,
she list into your shop.
But she's like,
you know,
fucking lady from,
I don't know man,
the man,
because they played,
remember when they played the reaction?
I was the British ladies answering machine.
Are they going to judge?
And they played her before she had the foreign accent syndrome and she was
really sad when she hurt herself.
She was like,
Oh I wish I could talk at this away again.
She did.
I remember,
I remember he was like,
Oh,
if we shot could talk like a decent yes.
Talk on like,
Oh this are now.
Yup.
This one,
I don't believe anybody that has clear braces to you.
That's what the other lady was talking.
Yeah.
I don't like it when people do the clear,
but what I do,
the Invisalign,
you know,
people can still see him,
but then you don't have,
you know,
nerdy ass clear braces,
gold school man get,
get the metal.
Do you think the clear braces are just worse than the old school metal ones?
Um,
I dunno,
cause you're not fooling anybody.
We still know that you have the brace from a distance,
but actually their mouth's still kind of,
that's what I'm saying.
You can still tell that's a piece so badly again.
Well,
well your honor,
could that be because like his show boating around with a lot of drinking
because she had not accustomed to drank in this much.
Are they going to think I'm lying?
Are they going to even understand how I'm speaking?
It doesn't sound,
here's the thing though.
A lot of these people,
I think the fakies sometimes you see it,
you hear it dip,
you know,
like it doesn't,
it doesn't sound like it's,
they're all Chinese accent lady had it one time.
Her,
she's like,
are they going to think I'm lying?
It doesn't sound 100% she's speaking like cockney she's not think I'm lying.
Like she kind of does like a lower class.
Oh Wow.
Interesting.
Winner of the poll.
Let everybody see that he can't hold his water.
We'll look at which I've drank because it's not accustomed for you if you drank
this much water.
You have to,
Pete,
what'd you say?
No one's a of meaning you because why?
This is an out of the norm for you know,
it doesn't matter or you drink the every day.
Wait a minute.
You don't drink this much every day,
so I do,
and your body still has to get rid of it,
but if he drank this much every day,
we never have to break twice for you to pay.
I'm drinking more this episode at this moment,
but that doesn't mean why.
Why are you drinking more this episode?
Why letting them know what I normally do after the show?
During the show?
Okay,
sure.
That's the only difference.
Go ahead and urinate again.
Oh Man,
who's exclusive now.
As soon as he was super abusive
and I'm like,
I turned her just then.
Now here's the part that I feel like I feel like you just don't get it.
No,
you don't get it.
you don't.
Let me explain.
You're like,
oh,
you're not used to it.
That's why you picked that are not used to drinking as much water.
That's not true.
How has that been finished and not true?
I'll explain it to you cause you don't get it.
You don't get a lot,
but
any lievable,
any body that consumes as much water,
whether it be the first time they ever did it or they do it every day,
your body has to get rid of the flu.
Yeah,
so you're saying like anybody who just down's half a gallon and an hour's not
like I'm used to it so it doesn't have to come out.
Not just that.
No,
not true.
You don't get it.
You don't get it because you don't hydrate as much as I do.
I can drink an entire,
you could not drink as much long skinny from trader's Joe car and sit in traffic
for an hour and my bladder accommodates because I'm so used to drinking so much.
No.
Expands and accommodates the,
the p the urine.
No,
you don't get it.
Nope.
You don't get it.
First of all,
you don't drink a lot of water.
this is all theatrical.
I'm going to prove that you're just doing this for the cameras and the cameras
are off.
It's dehydration city.
Your pee is Brown.
You're such an animal that doesn't prove anything and these people are just
totally being a sold a lie.
If you guys believe this fucking pony show dog and pony nonsense.
Oh my God.
All right Tom.
And now you're going to have to pee again.
Okay?
Okay.
You're gonna make yourself sick.
Seriously.
You're not supposed to drink a gallon of water.
You know,
it's really not good for you.
It is good for you.
And I'd do it every day.
Oh my God.
This is how kids on ecstasy die is overwatering.
It feels normal to me.
My vision is a little blurry,
but I feel fine.
Okay.
Could you stop now?
Um,
I think we got to wrap this up soon.
What do you got?
Yeah,
you got to go to the hospital,
Babe.
Okay,
bear.
That was my favorite.
She's like reasoning with them.
They'll forget it.
You're not supposed to be awake.
The a double pipe.
Classic shirt now on sale.
That is the coolest shit.
I gotta get one of those shows.
That is beautiful.
I love that.
Not Cool at all.
At the opposite of cool.
He was talking about the double pipe.
Classic Babe,
not I love Hentai.
You don't remember.
This is mostly an audio show.
Hi.
No that,
but there are people watching and,
right.
Does that make sense?
The people watching it.
Okay,
good.
Good.
That is the coolest shit.
I gotta get one of those.
Okay.
Well we're talking about dental pipe.
Classic shirt.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
You want to be so grouchy and abusive right now.
Yeah.
If you didn't force yourself to drink more water,
more than you normally,
usually this time of day
or drinking your Brown Cup of coffee and you're dehydrated for everyone watching
or not watching three quarters of a gallon down hour.
Good.
Anybody was a brain in their head knows that that's bad.
It's not bad to do in one sitting.
It's not a bad thing you've ever done.
Standard for bonds is not standing water champ.
Game flow.
She's a medical professional.
We can consult.
Yeah,
that,
that's so dumb.
I'm going to the doctor with number one.
That's first of all,
first of all,
we had our blood drawn at the doctor's office last week and they couldn't find a
vein on you because you're so dehydrated and when they did,
they pulled your blood out.
It was like syrup.
She goes,
because you're so d absolutely liar to such a filthy liar.
God,
how long did it take?
The nurse has to do with being fat.
No,
but she,
she pulled your blood out and it was like chocolate,
sir.
No,
she couldn't find.
She finally did and she goes,
you need to drink more water.
No,
she had to do water.
she didn't.
No,
I live with my sociopathic wire.
I live with a fucking psycho.
She said,
your blood's really thick.
You need to drink water.
No,
you don't remember those words ever.
She didn't really think it's so thick.
She did.
She did not make that up.
No,
she did.
How did I know?
How would I know that I'm not a medical professional.
Looney tune.
She offered me how apple juice cause your energy.
She didn't give me any apple juice or water because I was fine.
She goes,
your blood is too thick.
You need to drink water now you're so upset that you lost the h two o champ
fucking contest.
The vote came in your Bernie.
I'm Hillary.
I got nomination and you're like,
I'm still going to stay with 2% that were booboo booboo.
You lost deal with it and were delegates
lost cause you,
how are these fucking bumps?
These loses,
you know what?
I don't care anymore.
If they want to believe a lie,
let them like being hosted by Hillary over here.
All right,
we gotta get going.
I love you.
I don't want to be on email,
but I love you and I stopped loving you.
Thank you guys.
It's not a nice thing to say because it's not nice.
I just started loving you again.
Okay.
I stopped for those 30 seconds and then
I drank so much water because,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Thank you guys for listening.
Thank you guys for sending in all the funny stuff,
whether it be clips,
songs,
the translations,
a very fun episode.
For one part.
I didn't really enjoy it at all.
My kidneys hurt.
Please go to your mom's house,
podcast.com where can they buy the shirts?
They can go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the store or Tom segura.com.
Click on the store there.
I was just the shop button.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
if you just go to my site,
actually that'll be the shop for it.
Uh,
this outgoing song is by Credo and um,
that's it.
Oh,
here we go.
It's another fucking,
no,
it's not about you.
All right,
bye guys.
Your mom farts.
Farts.
Happy.
Jose.
The San Jose.
Happy hose.
He sat hose.
Don't
seismic Chrysler so fast.
Okay,
that's a good question.
First and alcoholic.
He's diabetic.
She's a sat at home and we were just talking about and he's so fat extra
and that's why fat,
no fat,
no fat.
Know I've been in and jail.
You know what I'm saying?
I did a little bit of everything.
I never had a job.
My life,
my stance,
face of golf.
It was telling me the Buddha nature is to be in the moment.
You know what I'm saying?
Chrysler so fast.
Seismic Chrysler so fast.
Okay.
That's a good question.
And Alcoholic.
He's diabetic.
She's a stay at home and we were just talking about stuff that he's extra
and that's what burst.
Okay.
Pack Tag.
Dj Dad,
mouth Hashtag Dj dad mouth.